In the last offer--
in the last video,
not the last offering.
I guess it was a bit of both.
We had completed our Series B.
We had gone back to the till.
Got another round of venture
capital funding.
And we raised $10 million more
that's going to help us build
out the website and do some
marketing, and hire up some
more engineers and
other employees.
And to do that we had to sell
one million shares.
We essentially sold them
at $10 a share.
And so after that offering,
well, our pre-money valuation
was $30 million and our
post-money is now $40 million.
That's the value of our assets
as-- I mean, the website,
that's kind of an arbitrary
valuation.
And I've gotten a letter
asking, well, how
do you value that?
And that's a whole subject
for another playlist.
And I will do that.
I will do a whole playlist
on valuation, eventually.
But, to get there, the first
thing to understand is just
the capital structure
and how capital
markets work in general.
So that's what we're
doing here.
But anyway, so after you got the
$10 million-- you had $30
million before, you get $10
million, your post-money is
$40 million.
And we had to issue a million
extra shares to do it.
So before the money we had three
million and now we have
four million shares.
So let me draw what our balance
sheet looks like.
So we had $1 million and then
we raised $10 million more.
So if we look at the left-hand
side of our balance sheet, we
have $11 million in cash, and
we have our website and
intellectual property.
Maybe we have some
patents now.
So you can say assets
of the firm.
I guess you could say non-cash
assets, right?
That's cash.
And some of them could be
intangibles, like branding.
Or maybe we made some small
acquisitions of other people.
And we'll do more videos on
actually the mechanics of
acquisitions and all that.
But you get the idea.
These are all of the other
assets of the firm, whatever
they may be.
And then on the equity side,
because we have no liability,
so in this case assets will
be equal to equity.
On the equity side of the
equation we just have four
million shares.
1/4 went to the Series B guy,
1/4 went to the Series A guy.
He had bought a million shares,
I think it was at
$7.50 a share.
Then the angel investor had
given us a million shares at,
and I think it was $5 a share,
that was the angel.
And then there's me and my
buddies, we split the last,
that first million
shares five ways.
And if I wanted to draw my
sliver, I still have my
200,000 shares.
And we could keep doing that.
We could get a Series C
and a Series D that
will keep us going.
But let's say that a couple of
other people have decided to
sell socks on the internet.
And we realize this
is becoming a
very competitive space.
And we really want to just
lay down the gauntlet.
And make sure that ours is
the dominant player.
Because we figure that whoever
gets the biggest market share
fastest, is going to become the
Amazon.com and everyone
else is going to turn into
these me-too players and
they're all going to
go out of business.
So size has benefits
in this situation.
So we don't want to do these
piddly $10 million offerings
and $20 million offerings.
We want to go big time.
We say, you know what?
We're going to expand our
company huge, we're going to
push marketing hard.
And so we want to raise
a lot of money.
Let's say-- let me make up a
number-- let's say we want to
raise, I don't know, we want
to raise $50 million.
$50 million to invest in
the business and do
some hard-core marketing.
And it happens to be at a time--
let's say it's 1999.
The stock market is
racing ahead.
People would love to get in
on this kind of stuff.
So we say hey, let's do an
initial public offering.
And then that has
two benefits.
One, we will be able to raise a
lot of money for the firm to
invest in maybe building
distribution centers or the
marketing that I talked about.
And the other side benefit,
which we won't really talk
about much at the board meeting,
but all of these
people right now, they're all
holding these shares, right?
I have these 200,000 shares.
This angel investor has
this million shares.
And there's really not a lot
they can do with them, right?
Maybe the angel investor, maybe
he had an expensive
divorce settlement and he has to
make some alimony payments
now, and he doesn't really
have the cash.
He can't do anything with
these shares, right?
Same thing with these VCs.
These VCs are accountable
to their investors.
And they can say-- like, this VC
can say oh, you know what?
I bought those shares at $7.50
per share, and then this guy
came and bought it at $10 per
share, so I already got a 33%
gain on my investment.
But the investors aren't that
impressed by that, because
you're still holding
the shares.
You can't really say they're
worth $10 until you actually
turned them into $10.
Or you turn them into
actual cash.
So, by doing an initial public
offering, all of a sudden all
of the players will
have liquidity.
Which means they can
exchange what they
have, including myself.
So they can exchange what they
have for actual cash
if they need to.
So how does that work?
So I would go to an investment
bank, although they've all
turned into commercial
banks now.
But we're talking in
a pre-2008 world.
I would go to an investment
bank and I'd say-- or more
likely they would come to me
and say hey, you guys could
raise big money in the public
markets right now.
Why don't you do an IPO?
And in a few seconds you'll
realize why they are
so keen to do it.
And I say, sure.
We can raise a lot of money.
And also we'll be in the press,
so that'll be free
marketing in and of itself.
So I say sure, do
all of the work.
So what they'll do, is there
will be a lead underwriter.
Let me write that down,
lead underwriter.
And that's essentially the
person who does all of the
legal work.
They're going to file documents
with the SEC that
describe the company.
And they're going to
make models and
projections and all that.
And then they're also going to
have people riding along with
them, other banks.
And they're going to
form a syndicate.
A syndicate is just a group of
banks that work together to
kind of handle a larger
transaction than any one of
them would be willing to
handle by themselves.
And it kind of spreads the
risk amongst them.
So the bottom line is what the
banks do, other than doing all
the legal work.
They'll value the company and
then they'll go to all of
their clients.
So all of the people who trade
through that bank, all of the
institutional clients, all of
the hedge funds that have
their prime brokerage accounts
at those banks.
And just so you know, a prime
brokerage account is just like
a brokerage account, but
it's a brokerage
account for big guys.
It's a brokerage account for
people managing $100 million
and not their E-Trade account.
That's all a prime
brokerage is.
And they'll go to these guys and
say hey, we have this hot
IPO issue, socks.com.
And we've done our models,
and we think this is
a $5 billion market.
We think that this company is
worth-- we think this company
is worth at least $100 million
in its current form.
So once again realize, I mean,
even though we're kind of
doing something a little
different now, all of the
other things were essentially--
you could call
them private offerings.
Or private placements
in some way.
Essentially these were
private equity sales.
And I know that word is used
a lot, private equity.
And that's what venture capital
essentially is.
Although normally when people
talk about private equity,
they're not talking about
venture capital.
And I'll do a whole other
video on that.
But venture capital
fundamentally is private
equity, right?
Because these shares that you're
selling, they're not
traded on a public exchange
like the New York Stock
Exchange or the NASDAQ, or
something like that.
So anyway, back to what
we were doing.
These guys, these banks, they
go to their clients and say
hey, I have this
hot new issue.
And they'll kind of
gauge sentiment.
They'll talk to clients, they'll
talk to each other,
and they say, oh you know
what the demand is.
And they'll essentially come up
with some price, which is
essentially as a high a price
as-- they want do a high price
because obviously as a company,
I want to sell the
stock for as much as possible.
But they don't want to do it
so high that the stock
doesn't trade up.
Most banks, you want your
IPO to look like this.
This is the first
day of trading,
this is your IPO price.
They want it to look like that,
so that in the future
when there's an IPO, people
get excited to get in it.
If this IPO-- if the stock just
did this, if it started
collapsing, one, people
will lose
interest in IPOs in general.
And then people will get
suspicious about this company.
And I'll do a whole
video on that.
So, how do the mechanics work?
Well, they'll say, hey, you want
to raise the $50 million,
well you could do it
a couple ways.
We say hey, we're willing to
issue another-- let me think
of the best way to explain--
we're willing to issue another
ten million shares, right?
And I'm not drawing
it proportionally.
Let's say we're willing to
issue another ten million
shares, and this should be a
lot higher, because this is
four million right here.
We're willing to issue a another
ten million shares,
how much money can
we get for it?
And let's see, these bankers
talking to essentially the
market, and talking
to each other.
They say hey, we think we can
justify these guys, and we're
going to do it for a little
bit lower than they're
actually worth.
But we think the market will buy
the fact that these guys
are worth, I don't know, let's
say they're worth $80 million
in their current incarnation,
right?
Which essentially says, before
we raise the money, we have
$80 million, we have four
million shares.
So they're saying $20 a share.
So if we go and issue another
ten million shares at $20 a
share, we'll actually
raise $200 million.
Actually, for the sake of-- so I
don't have to edit my math--
let's say that's how much we
wanted to raise, $200 million.
So essentially what these guys
will do, our board of
directors will issue
these new shares.
And then this syndicate of
banks, led by the lead
underwriter will then sell it
to their brokerage clients.
To mainly institutional
investors, but it might be
some favored rich guys.
If it's not that favored of an
IPO, maybe you might get a
call as well.
And they'll sell it
to all of them.
And you say, why are
they doing that?
Why are they doing all of this
work for the company, helping
them raise $200 million?
And they're going to the pain
of the legal work, and they
had to put a team of maybe
ten guys on this.
And they had to make models,
and it probably took them
maybe two or three
months to do it.
That's a lot of work,
what do they get in
exchange for all of this?
Well they actually
get a commission.
And that commission, at least
historically, has been 7% of
the offering.
7% of the offering.
And now you get a sense of why,
in a good market, when
you can do these things, why it
has, in history, paid to be
an investment banker.
Because 7% of $200 million--
and frankly it's not a lot
more work to do a $200 million
offering than it is to do a
$20 million offering,
it's probably
about the same amount.
But 7% of $200 million
is $14 million.
So actually these guys aren't
going to see $200 million.
They're going to see 200
minus 14 million.
So they're going to
see $186 million.
And then these bankers are going
to split $14 million.
And that probably is about
two months of work
for maybe ten guys.
So you can imagine-- and of
course they have the whole
bank that has the support, and
they have all these-- not
anyone could do this.
You have to have what they
call retail distribution.
You have to have kind of a
channel that you can plug
these shares into to
actually get rid of
the ten million shares.
You see, it's a fairly
profitable business.
So that's what an initial
public offering is.
For the first time, a company
is selling shares to the
public, that is not just to
these private investors.
And usually on an initial public
offering, although it's
not always the case, these
guys aren't selling their
shares as much as they
would like to.
They're usually locked in for a
certain period, just because
it looks bad if, especially the
insiders-- those were the
founders of the company--
actually sell their shares.
But six months later, then I
can go and sell my shares.
Maybe if I do it on a small
amount, I can go and sell it
in the NASDAQ.
And I have a publicly traded
price, so on any given day, I
know exactly what my
shares are worth.
And this is an important
thing to realize.
Because a lot of times when
people buy a stock they're
like, oh, I've invested
in that company.
Well, kind of.
When you normally buy a stock
on an exchange, as the New
York Stock Exchange, you're
just buying the stock from
somebody else.
You're not buying the stock
from that company.
So when you pay $100 for an IBM
stock-- I've run out of
space, that's why I'm just
talking and not drawing, let
me erase this.
I've run out of time, too.
But I think this is an
important point.
When you buy stock from someone
else-- so if I give my
$100 and I get a stock
certificate of IBM, most of
the time, if I were to do this
today, I'm just-- this is me,
with a mustache-- I'm just
getting it from some other
dude, right?
Well maybe he's happy
because he got $100.
He's got a top-hat.
And this is what happens in the
stock market every day.
So when I buy that, I'm not
really investing in IBM.
I'm just buying the money--
I'm just buying that share
from another guy.
We're just exchanging shares.
In an IPO, if I'm one of the IPO
investors-- this is me--
my $100 in this situation--
let's see we're
dealing with socks.com.
Maybe that's it's ticker
symbol, SOCK.
This time it's actually
going to the company.
It's actually going to the-- or
the website, in this case.
Of course 7% is being
re-directed to
the investment bankers.
So when you buying from and IPO
you really are, to some
degree, making an investment.
Just like if you were doing
a venture capital.
You really are making an
investment in a company.
Your money will then be used by
the company to hire people
and build factories
and make out a
website and do marketing.
In this case, you're essentially
just trading
shares in a secondary market.
Secondary market just means
that it's not going to the
actual company.
It's just going to another
shareholder who bought it
before you.
Anyway, I've really gone
over my time limit.
So I'll see you in
the next video.